[Music]
[Applause]
Courtney Cox attempts the Dirty Dancing
lip scene with longtime boyfriend Johnny
McDade and of course pal Ed Sheeran
makes a quick Cameo that's what I was
doing but the lift doesn't go quite as
planned
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah when Court asks her boo to try out
the iconic move can we do it the lift
sure this is how it actually went down
[Music]
[Applause]
yep it doesn't live up to the film's
fame scene but we know Courtney's all
for some comedic relief I enjoy those
I like it like when she had recreated
the routine from Friends
[Music]
check out Ed and Courtney killing the
choreo uncanny as Monica and Ross
[Music]
foreign
the big catch at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah they opted for a different approach
[Music]
[Applause]
when Courtney's not making hilarious
social media videos she's back to her
old friend stomping grounds on the
Warner Brothers lot filming her new show
shining Veil The Hat is a writer I
haven't written anything meaningful in
seven years I've been in a really dark
place lately my kids ignore me Terry's
at work I'm hoping that being out in the
country is going to help me find my muse
again do you get nostalgic from all your
time on the friends set when you come on
this lot does it bring you back at all
absolutely we've on stage five which is
where friends started is where the attic
is of you know yeah my characters where
she writes and where Rosemary visits her
and so yeah it's it's it's great I'm
with the commissary to be open I don't
mean the one I just want to sit in the
same seat that we used to sit in and get
the same salad and
um that's what I'm hoping for
[Music]
foreign